welcome back so we're talking about
machine learning models from data and we
want those models to be accurate and
fast and especially to be useful in the
future and so I want to dig in a little
bit more into what I mean by useful in
the future what it means for a model to
be generalizable and things like that so
when I say data from the past being
useful in the future when I say past I
really mean my training data so I have
some training data data let's say and in
the future this is where I am going to
be testing there's kind of this testing
data and this is one of the key
conundrums in machine learning is if I
had the future data I mean would I need
a model in the first place so I often
don't have access to the future I don't
know what I necessarily will see again
this is where the expert human comes in
to make those decisions about whether
the past is representative of the future
and so often what we do is we take the
data we have our data
let's I'm just gonna say we've got a
bunch of data and what I'll do is I'll
chop that data up into some portion that
I'll use for training so this is my
training and some portion that I'll use
for testing now this is all coming from
my historical data the data I've
collected this is my testing data this
doesn't have the future the future is
kind of out here this is the future but
what I'll do is I'll take my data that I
have and I'll split some of it up and
I'll use it for training and I won't use
any of the testing data when I'm
training my model on this training data
and oftentimes I'll use something like
80% of the data for training and maybe
I'll use 20% of the data for testing and
then what I'll do is I'll take the model
that I've used in blue here and I'll
apply it to my test data and I'll see
how well it was able to predict the
future
or this data that I held out and didn't
use for training so this is a
cornerstone of machine learning this is
an absolutely critical technique called
cross validation cross validation and
oftentimes what I'll do because I might
only have a limited amount of data and
this might be such a small test set that
I don't have enough information here to
be statistically to know statistically
how well I'm doing and so what I might
do is take my data and randomly
reshuffle it and take 80% for training
and 20% for testing
I might randomly reshuffle it again and
do it again and again and again and I
might average over a hundred times of
this random reshuffling training and
testing and so that's called k-fold
cross-validation so kay fold just means
how many times I randomly reshuffle my
data and use some for training and some
for testing okay and this is very useful
for certain types of tasks if I have a
task that's kind of interpol Ettore in
nature if i'm interpolating my training
data if what is in the future or in my
test set is an interpolation some some
kind of non-linear function of what's in
my training data i can probably build a
really good model using this
cross-validation framework but if i need
to extrapolate into the future that's
actually really hard to do in general
with machine learning so I like to think
about let's draw a little picture and do
an example if I have a cannonball
trajectory and so it's this parabolic
trajectory and I train my machine
learning algorithm on this blue region
it's actually really hard to develop a
machine learning algorithm that will
correctly extrapolate the behavior of
that ballistic ballistic trajectory okay
so this is something that's an example
that's not an interpolation where you
really need to generalize and understand
the principle of what's going on but in
cases where you just need to interpolate
Interpol Ettore problems image
classification audio voice recognition
ten
to be in that category if I have enough
data enough training data then most
problems can be made interpol Ettore or
a lot of them can at least okay and so
this idea of cross-validation or
randomly reshuffling your data so that
you can use some for training and some
for testing is how you can at least test
that your model might be useful in the
future now I'll give you a counter
example another counter example that's
really challenging and it's actually
very relevant is climate modeling so if
I want let's say I have a hundred years
of climate data okay and if I do this
random selection let me draw another
picture so I've got a hundred years of
climate data what I could do is randomly
choose 80% of my data across all of
those those years so I might pick 80% of
my data in that hundred year period and
I might pick the other 20% of the data
kind of in between those blue regions
and as you might expect I can actually
build a pretty good model based on this
blue data that I can use to interpolate
and predict this red data in the middle
but that's not actually a very fair
thing to do because that's not
necessarily representative of what the
actual feature is going to look like
because the actual future is not kind of
an interpolation of what I've seen in
the past we know that certain systems
are what are called non stationary
they're changing as time goes on and the
past is not going to be representative
of the future and so in the climate
modeling example this is actually a much
more fair thing to do if you have a
hundred years of data you actually have
to train on a chunk of that data a
consecutive chunk of that data and test
on the next or the previous consecutive
chunk of that data and this is much
harder because the physics here are
might actually be different than the
physics here this twenty years of
climate measurements are probably
physically fundamentally different than
these eighty years and so you have to be
really careful if you're if you're doing
something that you think might be an
extrapolation
that this can give you misleading
results where your your cross validated
error is low but you're not predicting
the future okay so that's that's another
thing you have to think about often that
would be kind of a manifestation of
overfitting in general I can over fit my
model to the training data in a way that
it still won't generalize to the future
okay so these are all important aspects
of how to build a model that is useful
in the future so what the future means
if it's an interpolation if I've seen
everything I'm ever gonna see like I
have all of these examples of cats and
dogs and every cat and dog in the future
is gonna look kind of like the cats and
dogs I've have in my training data then
you know this interpolation cross
validated machine learning models going
to work just fine if you're trying to
predict something you've never seen
before in a process that might be
changing that's a lot harder and you
might even have to bake in physics or
build your models to be generalizable
okay thank you